- Nous sommes allé
- Tremblant. Hum-hum,
et en vacances. Et T'choupi
aussi, avec "T'choupi"!pi", c'ee
pour enfants, mais il ne quitte
plus Olha...
- C'est devenu un outil pour
cette professeure d'université
de 49 ans qui a fui la guerre
ne avec sa fille
de 27 ans, Anastasia...
Nous les avions rencontrées
il y a 4 mois à l... elles ne pt
... elles ne parlaient
Si les blessures sont encore
quotidiennes avec la guerre
qui s'enlise, la vnde
et passe beaucoup par
l'apprentissage du français.
- Donc, les... bananes.
Avec "s" à la fin.
- En plus, des cours
de francratique
chaque soir après le souperaveci
les a prises sous son aile
leur famille d'accueil
québécoise.
- C'est
exceptionnelle. On ne regrette
rien, rien, rien, même
si parfo
qui sont difficiles.
C'est un investissement
à tous
les heures, de s'assurer
qu'elles apprennent le français.
la misère à expliquer
le français.
tout ce qu'elle peut.
- Il faut être rigide, puis
dit : donne-lui une pause.
Et je dis : non, on n'a pas
de pause parce que sa pause,ella
dans son appartement,
avec un emploi.
- Parce qu'avec le temps
qui passe vient aussi le désir
des familles ukrainiennesnt à r,
mais la réalité ne le permet pas
toujours, rappelle cette
- Notre grand questionnement,c'r
un appartement parce que
les propriétaires s parce que
la personne ne travaille pas.
- Et pour trouver un emploi
au Québec, il faut normalement
parler fez-vous, si on fait
rapidement un calcul, maman
est en cours de francisation
parce qu'elle ne parle
ni françelle a delle a delle a e
reçoit une allocation de 800 $
par mois. Est-ce qu'on peut
louer un appartement,
- Sans compter le manque
de places en garderie, bref,
un cercle vicieux difficile
à briser, à moyen terme,
- Je ne vois pas comment
elle pourrait teni
une conversation soutenue
pour un emploi avant au moins
(applaudissements)
- Avec l
les immigrants installés
au Québec depuis plus
des communications de l'État
exclusivrançais.
L'interprétation de plusieurs
Ukrainiens, c'est que
le français dans ces délais,
nt contraint contraint contrains
de quitter le Québec.
- Évidemment que je leur
Je leur dis : voyons donc,possin
dise que vous devez quitter,
que vous devrez quitter
ne parlez pas le françaisen six.
Mais reste que je sais que
les gens dans leur grande
inquiétude.
- Entre-temps, Olha et Anastasia
poursuivent leurs efforts
à la fois.
Ici Jacaudrey Cha